The wait for the trailer and title release
of the fourth Avengers movie nearly drove
the whole internet out of its mind.
But now that it's out in the wild, it's raising
way more questions than it answers.
Here are the biggest questions we're left
grappling with.
For all its many characters from across the
Marvel Cinematic Universe, Infinity War was
ultimately a movie about Thanos.
He set out on a genocidal mission, and at
the end, he won.
What's next?
We all know that the Avengers have unfinished
business with the Mad Titan but what are Thanos'
plans?
The trailer only reveals the warlord for the
briefest of moments, walking on the farm he
appears to have retired to just like he did
in the comics.
But what the comics don't tell us is what's
going to happen next.
Is Thanos simply done?
Or is there a second phase to his plan?
Does he know the surviving Avengers are coming
for him, or does he not see them as a threat?
Also why farming?
Does he just really like Stardew Valley?
The mind boggles.
One of the biggest questions swirling around
Endgame is just when the story will be picking
up.
One long-standing theory is that the movie
will begin after a time skip, picking up somewhere
in the vicinity of five years after the events
of Infinity War.
But the first Endgame trailer neither confirms
nor denies this theory, leaving the time period
ambiguous.
Some parts of the trailer, such as Tony Stark's
doomed jaunt through outer space, feel as
though they could be taking place within days
of the end of Infinity War.
Other parts, such as the reveal of the samurai
Clint Barton, feel like they could be years
down the line.
It's to the trailer's credit that we can't
decipher just when these things take place.
Both options are probably true, there may
well be a time jump, but it doesn't need to
happen immediately.
Right now, there's no way of being sure when
this movie is taking place.
"What year is it?"
The Avengers' initial plan of attack against
Thanos was actually going pretty good until
Peter Quill lost it and went rogue…
Thanks Star Lord…
Although it is worth noting that Team Titan
barely drew a draw a drop of blood off Thanos,
and he did whip Hulk with only one lousy infinity
stone.
So if brute force isn't going to win, what
will?
The Endgame trailer ramps up to a short exchange
between Captain America and Black Widow.
As Cap regards a picture of Peggy Carter,
the two superheroes discuss their upcoming
last-ditch plan.
Just what are these two preparing to go do?
And what does Peggy have to do with it?
The hot rumor that's been running around for
months now, based on leaks from the movie's
production, is that the Avengers will use
time travel to turn back the clock on their
catastrophic defeat to somehow change Infinity
War's outcome.
Whatever they're doing, we hope it corresponds
with Dr. Strange's mysterious plan.
Remember, out of millions of possible outcomes,
he only saw one way to victory.
Let's hope the survivors see it too.
"How many we win?"
"One."
After the exhausting Infinity War, we wouldn't
blame you for sitting out on Ant-Man and the
Wasp.
But those who skipped out also missed out
on a major cliffhanger one that the Endgame
trailer does away with in surprisingly casual
fashion.
In the after-credits scene for Ant-Man and
the Wasp, Scott Lang's Ant-Man uses some Hank
Pym technology in the back of his van to transport
himself to the Quantum Realm, the under-explored
micro-dimension of the MCU.
It's a uniquely dangerous domain, one that
the original Wasp was trapped in for years
before finally being rescued by Scott, Hank,
and Hope van Dyne.
As it turned out, Scott's jaunt into the Quantum
Realm took place at the exact same time as
Thanos' snap, leaving his partners on the
outside dusted and him stuck inside with no
obvious way out.
So it was a surprise to see Scott turn up
in the Endgame trailer acting as though nothing
had happened.
How did he get out?
Did he use one of those "time vortexes" that
Janet warned him about?
If so, what year did he end up in when he
left?
There’s this weird little detail hidden
right in front of our faces - if you look
really hard at the surveillance of Ant-Man
waving at the camera, it almost looks like
it says “1983”.
Did he pop out 35 years too soon?
And what about Natasha saying “it’s the
front door.”
Is this just a tricky edit?
hmmmm.
The ending of Avengers: Infinity War had some
tragic turns for everybody.
Poor Scarlet Witch had to watch her beloved
Vision die not once, but twice, and the first
time, she was the one who had to kill him.
When Cap lost Bucky, he lost both his best
friend, and his greatest link to the past.
But Rocket lost everything.
It was jaw-dropping to see how easy it was
for Thanos to wipe out all the Guardians of
the Galaxy.
We have to wonder if there's some reason why
Rocket was the only member of the team to
make it out alive.
Not only is Rocket still kicking, but last
we saw him, he was stuck on Earth, which is
not the most fulfilling place to be when you
look like a filthy raccoon.
"What's a raccoon?"
"What's a racoon?
It's what you are, stupid."
Has he taken up a permanent place at some
barstool south of Wakanda ? Or has he spent
all this time building bombs?
Either way, the trailer gives us no hints
as to what he might be up to since Thanos
killed all his friends.
The man formerly known as Hawkeye has been
missing in action for what feels like an eternity
but now he's back with a new name and an apparent
thirst for blood.
"Clearly retirement doesn't suit you.
Got tired of shooting golf?"
The trailer for Endgame seems to confirm all
the rumors that Clint Barton will be taking
up the mantle of Ronin for the fourth Avengers
adventure, trading in his bow and arrow for
the sword of a roaming samurai.
But one thing it didn't confirm is what he's
actually doing out there in Japan with that
new costume of his.
We can suppose with some confidence that Thanos'
decimation killed off Clint's whole family.
Why else would he have gone so nuts?
It's rumored that Clint is in the land of
the rising sun fighting the Yakuza, which
is cool if true, even if it is somewhat out
of nowhere.
Other rumors further indicate that the Yakuza
he's fighting aren't human people, but instead
alien Skrulls, a tantalizing, if totally unproven
possibility.
If he is killing Skrulls, how did he know
they were here on Earth?
Also, who is he working for, if anyone?
Aliens or no aliens, what is the goal of this
lonely warrior?
We don't know, but we've missed you, Hawkeye.
We know you would've gone for the head.